TEMPORARY BILL.
IT'S NO BIG DEAL.
REPORTER AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
SARA CARTER, GREGG JARRETT, MATT
GATES.
LET'S TALK ABOUT YOUR -- YOU GOT
A QUOTE TODAY IN YOUR ARTICLE.
TELL EVERYONE.
AMAZING.
>> YES, MEMBERS OF THE FBI, LIKE
THE TRUTH OUT.
FORMER SENIOR FBI OFFICIALS AND
CURRENT FBI OFFICIALS DON'T
BELIEVE THIS WAS JUST A
TECHNICAL GLITCH.
I CAN'T USE THE LANGUAGE THEY
SHARED WITH ME WHEN THE NEWS
CAME OUT.
SOMETHING THEY DID BRING UP
THAT'S IMPORTANT TO GET OUT TO
THE AUDIENCE.
THEY SAID A LOT OF THE TEXT
MESSAGES WERE DONE ON UNSECURE
SAMSUNG 5.
>> THE GLITCH.
>> YES THE GLITCH.
GERMANY, RUSSIA AND CHINA TRIED
TO CAPTURE FBI CELLPHONES ALL
THE TIME IT MAYBE A FOREIGN
ACTOR HAS THE TEXT MESSAGES
BETWEEN - .
>> VLADIMIR MAY HAVE IT AFTER
ALL.
>> SOMEONE MAY HAVE IT AFTER
THEY TALKED ABOUT FLYNN BEING
THE SUBJECT OF BLACKMAIL.
WHAT ABOUT THEM THE SUBJECT OF
BLACKMAIL.
>> I HAVE PEOPLE.
I DON'T WANT TO MENTION THEIR
NAMES.
THEY SAY SAMSUNG PHONES DON'T
HAVE POINT TO POINT ENCRYPTION
OR iMESSAGES AND THEY'RE
RETRIEVABLE MESSAGES THROUGH THE
CARRIER.
THEY WOULD HAVE A TIME AND DATE
STAMP, WOULDN'T THEY?
>> THEY WOULD IF THE EVIDENCE
WAS DESTROYED IT MAY OF BEEN
OBTAINED FIRST BEFORE IT WAS
DESTROYED BY THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL MICHAEL HOROWITZ.
THERE IS A INDICATION THAT IS
THE CASE.
IF SO WE WILL GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF THE DESTRUCTION OF EVIDENCE
AND DESTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
HERE, IF YOU WILL.
THIS IS FAR WORST THEN
WATERGATE.
EXPLAIN WHY YOU THINK . SO YOU
SAW THE MEMO WE DESERVE TO SEE.
>> ABSOLUTELY, SEAN.
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO DEMAND THE
RELEASE OF THE MEMBER OH, IT'S
NO LONGER DISPUTABLE A PRO
HILLARY CLINTON AN EYE DONALD
TRUMP BIAS AS INFECTED THE FBI.
YOU LAID OUT A TIMELINE BUT
THERE ARE MORE DAMAGING FACTS TO
COME.
TRUST ME, AROUND THE CORNER WE
WILL LEARN MORE ABOUT HOW
INFECTED THE INVESTIGATION IS.
STRZOK AND PAGE SAYING THEY WERE
THE INSURANCE POLICY AND SAVE
AMERICA FROM A TRUMP
PRESIDENCY --
>> YOU HAVE TO BRING US INTO
YOUR WORLD HERE.
MONTHS OF DARK PERIOD WITH THE
MEMO WE WANT TO RELEASE.
THESE ARE NOT ISOLATED INCIDENTS
THAT ARE SEPARATED FROM EACH
OTHER YOU HAVE TO EVALUATE THESE
TOGETHER.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THEY'RE
MISSING?
>> I DON'T BUY IT AFTERLY US,
HILLARY, BLEACHBIT, HAMMERING
DEVICES.
THIS IS BULL.
AFTER BARACK OBAMA PUT THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY ON DONALD
TRUMP THE TEXT MESSAGES WENT
DARK AND THEN THEY COME ALIVE
THE DAY AFTER ROBERT MUELLER IS
THE SPECIAL COUNCIL.
IT WOULD BE THE COINCIDENCES OF
ALL COINCIDENCES.
>> SARA, YOU SEE A CONNECTION?
>> ABSOLUTELY CONGRESSMAN GATES
BRINGS UP SEVERAL IMPORTANT
POINTS.
ACCORDING TO THE PEOPLE I HAVE
SPOKEN WITH THIS GOES BACK TO
2015.
THESE TEXT MESSAGES WERE SUPPOSE
TO BE STORED AND SHOULD BE
STORED.
THE MOST IMPORTANT FIVE MONTHS
OF THE INVESTIGATION ARE
FBI AGENTS, LAW ENFORCEMENT,
U.S. INTELLIGENT OFFICIALS
BELIEVE THESE WILL BE RETRIEVED.
GREGG, YOU MADE A GOOD POINT.
IF HOROWITZ GOT THE TEXT
MESSAGES WITHOUT THEM KNOWING
AND THEY WITHDREW, TRIED TO
CLEAN UP, THEY WOULD HAVE TO GO
TO THE RECORDS MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
AT THE FBI, HAVE SOMEONE HELP
THEM CLEAN THIS UP.
ABOUT HERE.
WHAT DOES THE LORETTA LYNCH
COMPONENT SAY TO YOU?
>> THE FIX WAS N AS YOU
DESCRIBED IT IN THE MONOLOGUE,
SPY ON STRUM AP ASSOCIATES.
THE PENALTY IS TEN YEARS BEHIND
BARS.
INCREASINGLY IT LOOKS LIKE THIS
WAS A WIDESPREAD NEFARIOUS AND
ILLEGAL PLOT TO FRAME DONALD
TRUMP AND CLEAR HILLARY CLINTON.
>> THANK YOU FOR YOUR HARD WORK.
YOU DESERVE PULITZERS.
AND JOHN, CONGRESSMAN, WE NEED
YOU TO FIGHT AND RELEASE THIS.